Speaker 1: I'm not going to spend a ton of time
on this, but there has been this viral moment
yesterday when President Joe Biden flew down
to Florida to survey the damage and to make
some announcements alongside Republican Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis, where Biden dropped an
F-bomb and said no one efforts with a Biden. And
of course, a bunch of Republicans are like, oh,
this isn't presidential. This isn't the right tone
to be striking. Huffington Post Article President
on Hot Mike with Florida Official No. One with a
Biden. He made the comment during what looked like
a laid back exchange with Fort Myers Beaches mayor
while touring the area damaged by Hurricane Ian,
Biden was recorded. One of this was one of
the areas hit by the hurricane. Murphy can
be heard. Ray Murphy is the mayor of Fort
Myers Beach. Murphy can be heard thanking
Biden for coming to the state before both
officials exchange the phrase Keep the
faith. And then Biden told Murphy, No one
with a Biden. So let's take a look at the
clip. And we do have to bleep it because we're
on radio and television and we don't want any
FCC problems for our stations. But if you want
the unedited version, it's easy to find one.
Speaker 3: Well, no one can argue outside
the house. That's exactly right. That's
exactly right. All right. Good to see. Thank you.
Speaker 1: Guys. All right. All right. So a bunch
of right wingers. Oh, this isn't presidential.
This isn't how a president should speak. Imagine
thinking this is a problem. So, first of all.
First of all. This actually is the real Biden,
right? Remember the classic when President Biden
was vice president and they signed Obamacare and
Biden was on a hot mic telling Barack Obama, this
is a big effing deal. He's just enthusiastic in
that way. It's the real biden, which i appreciate.
There was the peter doocy s.o.b. Hot mic incident.
Speaker 3: What do you think?
Unidentified: President biden is
my favorite political.
Speaker 3:
That's a great asset. More
information on the superstar moment.
Speaker 1: Okay. And so, you know, all the right
wingers have to do their dog and pony show about
it's unbecoming of a president and all this
stuff. If your belief was that one of the
great things about Trump was that he talked like a
so-called normal person and he told it like it is,
and he said what's on his mind. And you
don't have some fake reverence for elite
media people and all of that stuff, and it's
good when Trump does it. How can we possibly
believe you're really upset at Biden dropping an
F-bomb? Give me a break, guys. It is so pathetic
and contrived that we shouldn't even really give
it attention. And so I'm not going to spend more
than the 2 minutes on it that I already have. This
is Joe Biden. This is one of the things I actually
like about Joe Biden in the context of lots of
things I don't like so much. It is absolutely
implausible that these right wingers are actually
upset about this in this way. And if they are,
they're complete and total hypocrites. Let's take
a quick break and we'll be back right after this.